we have to ask ourselves in what society
are we living today what are the
organizing principles society are the
principles that lead to dignity or that
lead to the destruction of dignity I
personally believe that today we don't
live in a society that whose organizing
principle is dignity I think the
organizing principle of our society is
money that's that's that's a reality of
this society I don't think in any way we
are we have a society that is focused on
money no money no because money
ultimately relates to why do we want
people want money because money is a
tool and it's a tool to provide
opportunity and volition having money
gives you the opportunity to exercise
your volition and in that sense money is
is it's not a fetish it's not a god it's
not anything else it is simply a tool
and those who have more money have more
opportunities have more opportunities to
exercise their their nature to do good
to do evil to to what exercise their
pollution and so and so therefore it is
simply a reflection of everything else
we're talking at it's not you're making
the point that money dominates because
you're making the point that the more
money you have the more the more power
you have you make the point that money
is really the structuring the
structuring force in that society money
in that sense is a tool and government
is a tool and religion is a tool and if
you use those tools money government
power religion whatever to deny people
volition to deny people the
interrelation of humanists then that is
bad then that is but when I say that for
so many people it's not the truth if you
have it it's a tool if you don't have it
it's a perpetual daily humiliation and a
difficulty the kind of evil that keeps
me awake at night is the more inhuman
form of evil and that this bit closer to
your question when we create systems
you mentioned algorithms that nobody
understands it's a bit of an
exaggeration better do you think there
is some true for that we are good at
creating formal systems if you wanted me
to characterize modern civilization it
is that it's a form
Society we use formal rules to organize
ourselves and this has an amazing
scalability we can run much larger
society than ever before but the
downside is of course it might mean that
you don't need the human relations and
many of its scalable algorithm whether
they are software or in robots or in the
form of bureaucratic rules governing a
government or a university take a life
on their own and then you get what a
very good blog garyun and I called a
Moloch from there then even if we go of
the who had the child sacrifices to you
you set up something to give you value
whether that is a corporation or a
government or a defense system and then
it's not growing and it starts
destroying value
you still need to join up with it
because it forces you or because it's
the best thing to do and before you know
it you're working all the time and you
don't have a time for those pleasures
capitalist was supposed to give you or
the government that was supposed to say
the nation leads it straight into Abbas
so I think with Moloch's they are the
real friend money is instrument products
of artificial intelligence instruments
they demonstrated that they can live to
loads that the human person or these
muscles cannot live so these are
instruments in the hands of the human
person and the instruments become
whatever they become in the hands of the
human person the person who is using
them he can use them for Nobel scopes
and and he can use them for evil
whatever scores on em so money is an
instrument but when the pursuit of
acquiring this either to increase your
ability to whatever type that makes you
subject everything reacquisition of this
instrument then something is gone re
then then then we get in and it's
happened it's happened and in several
other forms which contribute to some of
the list items on your list human
trafficking is to make money into to
feed brothels
to feed you know all of those with
people so people can have whatever so
there are
there are cases where instruments take
over and direct the pursuit and the aims
of people in society and that s when
instruments cease to become instruments
and they become the values the dominant
values of people's lives and that's
where sometimes we can be looking at
evil we're talking about evil and evil
is a great word right it's got kind of a
Serpent's tail and teeth and it's
terrifying it's worth remembering when
evil came to came to kind of came of age
as a word that it would have been being
talked about probably in Latin and there
is no distinction in Latin between evil
and bad so suddenly it becomes a more
manageable concept Marlin they're both
Marlin which is incidentally also the
Latin word for Apple which is why in the
Garden of Eden they eat an apple it's
actually just a piece of fruit they just
like the pun but my point is is that
while we would all hesitate do you do
evil no I don't do evil do you do bad
well and I actually think it's an easier
discussion almost to think of the bad
you do and the ways in which you do bad
rather than evil and then suddenly you
can see that with these many many clicks
that we do when we buy something from
Amazon and and supporter support an
industry in which workers have no rights
that these are the evils these tiny tiny
tiny incremental dying by a thousand
cuts rather than evil that we do today
is not evil sounds like me standing up
from this chair taking a sword and
chopping someone's head off
you